for more information on tutoring or how
to support moofy university and the
production of more videos please visit
moof university com thank you and enjoy
next is positron emission or beta plus
emission a beta plus particle or a
positron is represented like this pretty
much the opposite of an electron right
so instead of a negative one for the Z
value it's kind of one and it's got a
positive charge so it can be represented
in any of these ways with the beta plus
or just the beta or the e plus or just
the e but as long as the Z is positive 1
sometimes you go put the plus sign in
front of the one I'm not really a fan of
doing that so a positron is the
antiparticle of an electron okay so just
just the opposite of it okay so let's do
this example carbon 11 is the parent
here got a mass number of 11 z of 6 that
means that the n will be 11-6 which is
five and the positron over here has an A
of zero and a Z of one and so it's n is
zero now what's going to happen as far
as the daughter let's just balance it
right if I over here on the left side is
11 over here the a from the beta part
the beta positive particle the positron
is 0 so VA here and the daughter is
going to be 11 what is the Z going to be
well it's six over here and it's one
right here so it's got to be it's got 1
plus 5 is equal to 6 so we got 11 as the
mass number 5 is the atomic number so
we've got boron if you look on the
periodic table for the number 5 de Tomic
number 5 you'll find B which is boron ok
so let the n value there 11-5 is six ok
so let's think about how these values
change the mass number stay the same
these because we go from 11 to 11 the
z-wave from six to five so it decreased
by one
and the N went from five to six so that
increased by one this is pretty much the
opposite as far as Z and n go this is
the opposite of the beta minus decay
right here it's the same same as the
beta minus decay right the beta minus
particle did not affect the mass number
it affected ZZ and the end here's the
same but the results of as far as Z and
n go are the opposite okay and so the
general form can be written like this
the aides say the same Z decreases by 1
and I'll put a little cloudy box around
that a little cloud so so why does this
happen when would this occur well
positron loop that supposed to be a plus
sign there looks like a minus positron
emission occurs when there are too few
neutrons so this is basically the
opposite situation for beta minus decay
goes right then in beta minus decay
there were too many neutrons Albert too
few so in this case what happens this
converts a proton into a neutron and a
positron okay so proton turns into a
neutron and positron so if we show that
with the notation here right 1 1 1001 up
here the mass number is 1 and 0 add up
to equal one and the Z's add up to equal
one so this checks out as well so in
this case since there are too few
neutrons it takes a proton and turns it
into a neutron and a beta beta plus
particle that's emitted so the opposite
effects essentially of beta minus decay
so I hope that video is helpful thank
you for watching if you found that video
helpful don't forget to Like comment
subscribe and share with friends thank
you and happy studying